well when I take a trip I I used to
travel a lot and I would go to Africa
and I would go to various projects there
was always a lot of people had projects
want me to see him and oftentimes I
would go there and walk through and see
and then I'd sit down with kind of the
the village elders you know we'd sit
under a tree and I would just listen to
them talk I always had an interpreter
and they would talk and tell me some of
the things that they were wrestling with
and what the problems were and you know
that there was always some I would
always sometimes there would be an issue
in which you know there were common
issues among countries but sometimes
maybe this particular village had a real
problem that really needed a special
special hand or something like that and
maybe I could come back and I knew all
the nonprofit organizations and I could
I could without even going to my
constituents are going to the government
I could call up a friend and world
vision and say look you've or I have a
good friend in South Africa that's got
two drills water he Joseph or water so I
got a village I want you to go into
would you think about it and he eats
said well it's going to cost some money
and I said well why don't you go ask for
money for a ID and send me your bed and
I'll not your bed but if you're going to
contact with him out I'll try to put a
good word in free because I've been to
the village and tell him you need this
so you know I would do it that way I
wouldn't always go to my district
because you know it was a local thing
but if it was a thing like Ethiopia
where a million people had died that was
a very easy thing to do because I would
come home and I would give a report and
I since I was the first person the first
congressman to go to Ethiopia during
those days when I came home
there you know the press was so eager to
report it that they reported it widely
and I was able to tell them what I had
seen and what they needed and we were
able to rush a lot of aid and they're
very quickly we were able to put a lot
of food in there a lot of medicines a
lot of blankets a lot of NGOs really got
geared up and i was able also to go back
and get my district geared up you know
it was a way for me to bring my district
into it and we did a we did a 40-hour
fast in my district and there's this was
something my bar I borrowed from another
NGO so we started a fast on Friday night
went till sunday at noon and for every
hour you at fast you would go out and
and raise money in your in your area and
I got big business corporations to back
me and students would get their their
parents or moms and dads to back to him
and and then we had all kinds of people
and then I brought a bunch of
ambassadors ambassadors in from the
countries that were affected by the
famine that surrounded Ethiopia and we
had a series of lectures and we had then
people would come in and sell their
wares from those places we had we had
fun I mean we had you know but we it
wasn't a fast in that it was strictly
water the you could drink fruit juices
if you wanted and but we didn't need for
40 hours we raised almost around a
thousand dollars over the weekend
half of wench half of which went
overseas and if you wanted it if you you
know you told us well I want this to go
the Jewish relief group fine I want to
go to the Baptist okay so we'd give it
to whoever you wanted to go to the other
half stayed in my district and went to
the 66 food banks so we were helped able
to help through the famine in Ethiopia
domestic and international so it depends
on the situation and each village each
country was unique and different but it
was if it was a big famine and it
affected many countries I would just
report back to Congress and I would push
through legislation if I could or more
money or food more medicines